he is the Harvard professor psychology
professor whose news bestseller is
enlightenment now the case for recent
science humanism and progress Steven
Pinker
[Applause]
[Music]
I have been following you for a very
long time and I've always felt you were
a necessary corrective to the kind of
society we live in where the media is of
course by their nature never reporting
the good news and you're the guy who has
and whenever I've quoted you to people I
must say you can tell it's shocking
because they're shocked that the good
news is what is shocking to people so
why don't you give us like the top few
things that under you talk about poverty
and health around the world that have
greatly improved in the 21st century the
people are not really that aware of well
will be we can begin with life itself
through most of human history right life
expectancy at birth around 30 now it's
71 worldwide and 80 in the more
developed parts of the world education
through most of human history the vast
majority people were illiterate now 90%
of people under 25 in the world can read
and write wealth and poverty by the way
and in poll polls show that virtually no
one knows these facts that people are do
worse than as Hans Rosling put
chimpanzees picking bananas because the
chimpanzees pick at random and people
are systematically too pessimistic
wealth and poverty 200 years ago
90 percent of the world lived in extreme
poverty now it's ten percent in fact the
rate has been reduced by about 50
percent just in the last 25 years every
day 137 thousand people escaped from
extreme poverty that's like more than a
billion people just in the last couple
of decades and by the way this is
somewhat connected to Trump voters
because one reason why people are in
less poverty around the world is because
jobs do go there we used to have here
Dow people who used to work at
subsistence level now they're working in
a sweatshop
and that's actually a step up right yes
free trade has been not been good for
everyone but it's been on average good
for humanity as a whole piece even
though there are horrific wars that
continue to go on the rate of death in
in war worldwide is about a quarter of
what it was in the 80s about 1/7 of what
it was
in the 1970s during the war in Vietnam
to say nothing about what it was in the
early 50s during the Korean War or World
War two safety we are about 95% less
likely to be killed in a car accident a
plane crash to be mowed down on the
sidewalk to be to die in an industrial
accident even to be struck by a bolt of
lightning or 99% safer than our
ancestors were a century ago
lightning mainly few people few people
work outdoors okay furiosa farmers i
tell you i was trying to figure out a
way for a few years to do something on
the show about what I called issue
fatigue because there's so many issues
in our audience is a caring audience
they are they would if they weren't they
wouldn't be watching this show what a
stupid [ __ ] they could watch so I I
wrote down just in one week I just wrote
down all the things you could worry
about that I read about Isis ice caps
melting depleted groundwater
identity-theft Russian meddling rape on
campus opioid addiction I'm not done
antibiotic resistant germs coral reefs
are dying colony collapse disorder the
bees are dying violence and football
drought flooding brain-eating amoebas a
billion people still defecate in the
street
police racism oceans are lawless and
polluted solitary confinement is
overdone the EU was breaking up refugees
Church pedophiles PTSD and veteran
suicide we're bullying homophobia
sinkholes infrastructure crumbling
longer commutes factory farm runoff
plastic Texas endocrine disrupters team
driving running out of water and then I
read that we're running out of sand
because that's what they make glass out
of we're running out of sand and then I
saw this cover of Newsweek the your
office is Kelly I like Oliver is the
problem right the onion had headlines
CNN holds morning meeting to decide what
viewers should panic about for the right
I mean we should worry about all these
things but it's kind of a cheap trick
because of at any point in history if
you list all of the worst things
happening I get in the world it can
sound pretty sad but I I can I think I
could burst your bubble with just two
nukes and pollution because all this
good stuff as true as it is and it's
great that you're saying it all it takes
is a few nuclear bombs to go off and it
wouldn't just screw up where they went
off it would screw up the whole planet
well we take a whole planet yeah but if
India and Pakistan exchanged their
nuclear weapon wouldn't Arsenal's yeah
it wouldn't have just a few that
wouldn't just be those countries that
died off I talked about that and that's
possible that is possible and we should
be giving much more attention to it than
we do to terrorism and emails and a host
of other issues and also I don't know
how the people who are walk they walk
back the idea that they said 10 15 years
ago we only have 10 more years before we
have to do something drastic about
climate change
well that was 15 years ago I mean what's
going on in the world today I mentioned
a little bit in the monologue that the
record heats I mean people dying in
Japan and places where they never did
from heat
we're not even starting on that well we
are starting on it we're not doing
nearly enough and it is the greatest
threat face facing you
but there are road maps to decarbonizing
the economy that we have to implement
and accelerate they include both policy
measures like a carbon tax so that every
economic decision that everyone on the
planet makes factors in that's doing it
that's the thing there is no carbon to
start yeah are you first carbon tax am I
am
look there's a good Democrat say just
[Applause]